hey everyone I want to share with you a
brand new channel and it's called
Brainiac and what they do is combine
education and entertainment to answer
most of life's most interesting
questions
Brainiac presents all these amazing
facts that you wish you learned in
school and they use high quality
animation and voice-over to give you a
super funny experience that you will not
forget that's right what would actually
happen if you woke up someone who was
sleepwalking
have you ever wondered what would happen
if you were sucked into a black hole
octopuses look like aliens
maybe that because they are Brainiac
facts are perfect for showing off your
knowledge and flexing that
intelligentsia go to the link in the
description below and check out the
channel now clickety click it for your
brain in its all the live news submitted
by Rob from Maine a man ate expired food
for a year to prove why expiration dates
are practically meaningless that's
called the Chinese cuisine here we go
back to normal - yeah that's what
dumpster divers say Oh ever since I was
I grew up my mom be like oh it's just a
few days after the expiration it's fine
it's just it's a money thing yeah it's
all the money thing it's just that's all
it is like milk cheese or those notes
and I was like [ __ ] though well what it
smells like [ __ ] you got throw it away
but there's a lot that after the date
you could still like maybe a week maybe
even before the expiration they're just
gonna close yeah yeah so like that is
like the milk is like milk and young
girls they had the same thing you have
to keep checking if they're good you
know yeah how young we talking though
you know like eight nine 19 20
it's safe and you know 18 of 25 yeah
yeah keeps melanin no you said your
relationship didn't work out you know
what call y'all again that's in another
video
no but I think that the expiration dates
it's all a money play for so we had so
week we can't have to keep buying new
food and also because like they we have
these like minimum standard regulations
that we have that we foresaw on society
because lawsuits yeah even if you go to
like bakeries the day-old bread is all
of a sudden the dollar but yesterday it
was like eight dollars what's this guy's
reason so this guy he is the founder of
this grocery store called mom's organic
market and so his name is Scott man the
working title should have been old-ass
food Mexican market oh no that makes a
lot of the Mexican markets are like when
they get like this
the Ralph's food and that Whole Foods
food that are like it's right before
market already comes like got orange
with one green dot on the side just some
of them have bigger green mold that's in
the other one any of those little Marla
those little markets and you get like
really good deals
that's the produce that you know they'll
meet the cut yeah didn't make the cut I
tried so cheap though Scott here he ate
a cup of yogurt Monday Oh
well yogurt technically already spoiled
yeah yeah but it grows mold yeah but you
know mom and my grandma used to cut the
mold off the cheese we still so bad
do you watch videos on that like you
shouldn't eat around mold he's still
alive I guess what about bread not on
bread yeah
Oh bread you're safe no you're not
supposed to eat over my mom always just
cut that off well you're not supposed to
like I watch I'll watch some youtube
videos on it what do they say oh you're
still in there
like the you can't see them yet they're
still in there though and what happens
you get sick I don't know I didn't watch
that far I was like made a sandwich and
you been eating eating and you go oh
[ __ ]
you wouldn't like look at the sandwich
first and be like it's got mold chill
like you wouldn't like do that I just
see it around it yeah have fun yeah I
know you're still yeah yeah that's good
logic oh then you're you and you're you
and your YouTube research cuz it's like
I was like wait don't eat red with mold
on it okay got it
look I don't need any more information I
think a little mold is good for you I
definitely I don't eat the potatoes at
search brow ting cuz I heard that was
bad yeah okay you just put this broth
off you know I read that you don't I
thought you just that's how you grow new
potatoes you want those ones you can
have two potatoes oh there's something
crazy toxic oh [ __ ] we don't know [ __ ]
well okay
so they're saying here that our Scott
thing here that he accidentally ate this
yogurt after like way way way past its
expiration date he was like oh it was
actually fine you put in a smoothie and
then he also ate tortillas past the
expiration
they smell sour yeah that's just nasty
which tortilla corn or flour give you
guys
our staple all right nope no household
oh no you soon as you said tortilla all
of a sudden you like it took you back
right Barbie you know it's like you put
all the extra time I made us quesadillas
with like four month altered years
coming in he pushed it out we were okay
and I think was the the flower kind
those ones they lie to you the corn ones
if they'll go that fast
yeah yeah all right well so here's what
else did he eat I'm about to show you
here are some of the foods that he
consumed it 15 days past expiration
that's not bad that's normal no way meat
doesn't matter haven't you ever had like
like a 35 day age to steak you know they
they keep it in line so it's dry they do
it a certain way no but when you go to
like you know you can really get steak
house and they'll be like oh this is for
50 days this has been marinating you
know oh yeah this is just like straight
package oh you just had it in the
refrigerator yeah it says almost a full
year after best by date stored in the
refrigerator and mate great cassette he
has with this but what we don't know is
he was his stomach hurts all the time
that's probably the [ __ ] that it came
out green this one he this was a tub of
butter
he doesn't need a tub of butter it got
moldy inside get moldy sitting in his
fridge for months and then he scraped
off the mold and he used it bought the
most of the butter to cook with it he
didn't spread it on so he cooked yes the
heat would kill yeah but you know what's
so crazy you know if you think about
some of the nasty things you've done
sexually
we've put nastier things in our mouth
I've never had sex
all someone yeah you ever had sex what
in the daytime
all my holes have been violated yeah so
they're saying that you know if you toss
out it perfectly at a bull cup a cup of
yogurt every once in about it once in a
while doesn't seem that bad but it adds
up because they're saying that 84
percent of consumers at least
occasionally throw out food because it's
close or past its package date and over
1/3 which is about 37 percent say that
they always or usually do so we waste a
lot of food and so that food waste in
landfills it generates carbon dioxide
and methane which is a greenhouse gas
that's 28 to 36 times more effective at
trapping heat in the atmosphere than
carbon dioxide so it's not just about
like wasting the food or wasting your
own money but you're also wasting all
the resources that went into growing and
packaging and transporting that food and
then you're creating green greenhouse
gases when you throw away that food
because it's sitting in the landfill so
it's a lot of bad happening and so right
now what this one woman she's her name
is Emily she's from Harvard Law School
food law and policy clinic she is saying
that there's need to there needs to be
changes made that needs to be federally
mandated by law they should be packaging
labels a certain way or food labels a
certain way but right now the FDA they
just kind of like suggest it's like well
we suggest you do this but it's not by
law the only the only federal law that
exists that requires dates on food is
for infant formula it's the only one
everything else it's like up to you and
so all the expiration dates are just
suggested yeah well so they're there's
so many different terms that are being
used on package labels but the two that
they focus on this article is that it
should be at least either best if used
by date which is the quality of the food
like if you use it by this date like you
it tastes the best
it's like the quality it's not it's not
that it's gonna be unsafe for you to
consume but the you know they use by
dates is that's the one that it's it
won't taste good after you use it and so
it might not be a good idea for you to
consume that product and it's mainly for
dairy or like the really highly
perishable foods those are the ones that
should be tossed out or used or tossed
out by that date the use by date but
then there is sell by date as well and
then there's just so many other terms
but they're did I guess some bananas in
my freezer right now that are just like
you know I think bananas in a freezer
are gonna be okay oh that's me yeah but
they're totally black that's why they do
that when they oxidize oh you put them
back okay good Bill Nye the Science Guy
Oh or banana Pike everyone says that
those are good banana bread but who the
[ __ ] is making some name all the time I
used to always that went bad I couldn't
wait do you just make banana bread in
the oven it's pretty easy yes Bob it's
really good what's your banana bread the
recipe you're like a secret secret I can
tell you isn't it what is it just like
flour and bananas it's a secret jazzy
create 13 [ __ ] ingredients oh you
understand I can tell you one tell me
what bananas yeah I don't think you know
how to get Z we should bother here one
time you weren't here it was really good
here's somebody don't know we're way
around the kitchen huh I don't cook no I
didn't see Tuesday and then that's how
you learn to cook oh yeah it's been it's
been five years of doing desi Tuesday
and I'm like I could cook anything go
check it out not anymore though right
you don't want to do it every weekend
you know I'm on a diet right
almost once so I have a bit it's been
hard to pick out recipes that are on my
diet what I was trying to do brandy
about the new segments that you have
thanks Jeff
I made stickers on my channel the other
day yeah so go check it out I know Steve
mentioned a lot of people were
commenting like sticky
gianna see you make stickers since Steve
mentions it on JK news I don't know what
he says about me on this channel a lot
that I know I just hear it from other
comments things I like worship moon rock
said like only hang out with people of a
certain astrology sign yeah
sounds pretty accurate thanks but yeah
anyway so have you guys don't food out
that you think oh absolutely yes but I'm
throwing it up because of the day
because I'm definitely one of those
people yes sometimes the date says it's
okay and I feel it and it's slimy yeah
and I'm like nope yeah for me it's like
like strawberries oh yeah the giveaways
are the one sex
no but bloom is you don't even know
until you bike yeah yeah that's the work
that one [ __ ] bastard blueberries
wait on them you get a look at it
sometimes a little stem part of it like
you haven't really have to oh yeah
starting each one - that's a lot of work
you could tell like I like the this the
more firm ones the more firm if it
doesn't taste good I spit it out yeah
there must be enough it seems like when
they're bad you know they're bad
no not sour they're like um like a like
a fermented almost yeah like you look
like you have some wine banana bread or
blueberry wine what is this Texas banana
bread and blueberry wine
[Music]